- All right let's wrap this hour up
with something absolutely
adorable from social.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Like most mamas Chanele
loves taking pics and videos
of her little girl Sailor and
sharing them on social media
for friends and family to
see, 'cause she's adorable.
And one year old sailor is
always up for a quick shoot,
not long ago Chanel tried something new
and experiment of sorts,
she taped Sailor trying
to pour water into a glass
and TikTok went wild.
This video popped with more
than 1.5 million views,
that's it, She see,
well some of the water
made it into the cup.
Some of it did,
we have Chanel and Sailor
on the line right now.
Hi
(audience applaud)
- Hi, Kelly
- Oh my God, you both are so beautiful.
- Thank you, so are you
- Oh my goodness you are so cute.
So can you tell us more about
her TikTok in this video?
- Yes, so I started her thing
so our family and friends back
in Texas would be able
to watch her grow up.
And when my son was a baby,
I had so many adorable photos
of him that I ended losing
because they weren't backed up.
So, I just thought I
didn't want the same thing
that happened in her baby years.
And a few weeks ago, I saw little kids,
pouring different liquids in the cups
and I wondered if Sailor be
able to do something like that.
She got it right away
she was so focused and you can tell
that she was enjoying herself.
So, I posted it and everything came that
it was gonna go viral.
- Oh, it's adorable.
(audience applauding)
So you've since made more
sailor pouring videos, right?
- Yes, reading through the comments.
I noticed the fans are
wanting to see more Sailor
pour different liquids in the cups.
So, we've done yogurt and soda,
but the messiest of
them all has been milk,
but the milk did get everywhere,
but I definitely don't
mind cleaning up the mess.
I'm a mom of two, so I'm used
to cleaning up big messes.
- Oh my gosh, it is so cute.
Thank you so much Chanel and Sailor
Thank you Sailor
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, bye.
- I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show
thinks that your video is
as funny and cute as we do.
So, in recognition, they're
gonna be using their friction
erasable pen to write you a
check for a thousand dollars.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.
That's amazing, thank you, goodbye.
- All right thank you so much.